that haggis
it's a creative idea it's fun it's
inventive the spice level is perfectly
pitched
it's the sort of thing that could set
this restaurant apart from other thai
wrestlers in the country
absolutely loved it and that kind of wow
factor
my god can i try a glass of the white
thai wine i do
can i just try a little bit okay
what if it's not very nice wine i won't
want to drink it wow
that's not how we offer wine services
sandy
no that's a bit of a shock to it yeah
okay if you don't like it you don't have
to have it
okay
actually looked at me
would he behave like that if you were
there sandy
i think not what more likely to do would
be probably to come and ask
what to do about the situation damn it's
not ideal
it is appalling i'm just shocked in all
honesty
hold on a minute i asked for a glass of
thai wine
uh okay are you gonna let me speak okay
and you give me the evil eye
and you say to me i'm gonna you have to
pay for that wine
and then and then you say to me if you
don't pay for that one i'm gonna go and
call the police
sir do you call that decent service dude
i'll pay for it but i mean that's just
absurd that ranks as about the most
aggressive service i've ever seen in my
life
oh my god
i'll call the police
i'm lost for words
incredible what i would love to have
is i'll put out an olive branch to the
manager
he takes it we kind of kiss and make up
figuratively speaking excuse me either
hi there um what's happening with the
hawaiians
to be honest you know like i didn't
mention it i'm not gonna charge you food
price but i have to chat you have places
you know all right well i didn't you
know all this business with the police i
thought it was very strange
i don't want to admit with the customers
sandy how does it make you feel when you
see that style of service been running
your business
yeah i'm both shocked very embarrassed
and uh
not more than a little bit angry overall
that's been
a very energizing experience on many
levels
i'm enthusiastic and excited about the
quality of the food
the service has been smiling courteous
apart from the one blip
and i'm leaving here thinking i would
definitely come back here and i would
tell people about it
and they're the two things that when
you're a restaurant owner you really
want your diners to leave